>> Laura: I LIKE THAT FACT --
ALL RIGHT, HANNITY.
IT IS GREAT TO SEE YOU ENTITIES
YOU.
I AM LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
TIPPING OVER AND FALLING DOWN.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WE COULD START THAT SHOW THE
EASY WAY TONIGHT ON BIDEN'S
DISMOUNT SKILLS OR WE COULD JUST
FOCUS ON THAT WE ARE WHISPER
THING HE DID TODAY ON THE BEACH.
>> President Biden: I AM ALSO
VERY PROUD OF THE STATES LIKE
DELAWARE.
[WHISPERING]
>> Laura: WHY DOES HE DO THAT?
OR BECAUSE POKE FUN OF THE AT
LEAST ONE PERSON ON THE FACE OF
THE PLANET.
LIZ CHENEY.
>> CAN THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OBEYED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES?
IMMEDIATELY WOULD HAVE PLUNGED
INTO WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
TANTAMOUNT TO A REVOLUTION
WITHIN A PARALYZING
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
>> Laura: BUT INSTEAD, LET'S
TALK ABOUT WHAT MATTERS, SHALL
WE?
IT IS ABOUT THE FUTURE.
THE RESTAURANT ESTABLISHMENT IS
LOSING ITS ABILITY TO GOVERN
COMPLETELY.
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE FRENCH
PARLIAMENTARY ELECTIONS OVER THE
WEEKEND WAS ABSOLUTELY STUNNING
AND AMERICANS SHOULD PAY
ATTENTION TO THIS, PRETTY BOY
LIBERAL EMMANUEL MACRON LOST A
GOVERNING MAJORITY DRIVEN BY
HUGE GAINS BY THE RIGHT AND LEFT
WING PARTIES.
THAT THERE IS LOOK AT THERE'S
BEEN AN UNDERCURRENT OF
DISCONTENT BUILDING THROUGHOUT
EUROPE AS WORKING PEOPLE WERE
FALLING FOR -- FURTHER BEHIND.
THIS WAS PRECEDED BY THE ISLAMIC
REFUGEE INFLUX AND NO
INFLATIONARY CONCERNS AND THAT
UKRAINE RUSSIA NIGHTMARE.
RATHER THAN ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THEIR PEOPLE, THE OLD EUROPEAN
CARD SEEMS OBSESSED WITH LIFTING
UP DEPENDENCIES OF THE NEW
GLOBAL ORDER.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
TAMING CAPITALISM, PUNISHING
BOTH CREATORS, AND OF COURSE,
BIDEN'S TOTALLY ON BOARD WITH
THAT.
>> President Biden: WE CAN
MOVE IN THE DIRECTION THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE FOUR [INDISTINCT] IN
THE CORPORATE AREA AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUALS AS IT RELATES TO
[INDISTINCT].
>> Laura: HOW ORIGINAL.
HIGHER TAXES.
I HAVE NOT HEARD THAT BEFORE.
A POLITICAL ELITES ARE NO LONGER
NIBBLE BECAUSE EVEN WHEN THEY
BRING IN A CHARISMATIC NEWCOMER
LIKE AN OBAMA WORK EMMANUEL
MCCRONE, IT DOES NOT WORK BECAUE
THEY ARE TRAPPED IN THAT SAME
OLD CYCLE OF TAX, SPENDING, AND
DIVIDE.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN OUT OF THEMES
FOR -- STEAM FOR MANY YEARS.
>> BUDGET UP SPENDING.
BUT MANY IN THE ECONOMY.
HE TRIED TO KEEP BUSINESSES
OPEN, TRY TO KEEP PEOPLE WITH
INCOME IN THEIR POCKETS AND
WHENEVER YOU DO THAT, YOU RUN
THE RISK OF CONFLATING THINGS.
AND WHAT YOU THEN HAVE TO DO IS
TRY TO FIND SOME BALANCE IN ALL
OF THAT.
WE ARE SEARCHING FOR THAT
BALANCE.
WE WILL GET THERE.
>> Laura: THE BALANCE?
THE VOTERS ARE ALREADY THERE.
THEY SEEK WITH THE BALANCE IS
PAID.
THEY ARE OUT OF PATIENTS THINK
THAT TIME HAS COME TO THE
QUICKNESS THAT HISTORY HAS
ENTERED A NEW CHAPTER.
THE OLD SOLUTIONS THAT MIGHT
HAVE WORKED TO SOME EXTENT BACK
IN THE '90s DON'T EVEN MAKE
SENSE TODAY.
WE HAVE TO FORGET TALKING ABOUT
A NEW REPUBLICAN MAJORITY.
TO QUOTE NEWT GINGRICH, WE NEED
A NEW AMERICAN MAJORITY NEW
COALITION FOR.
IN THE FOLLOWING REFORM HAS TO
TAKE PLACE.
WE HAVE TO PROMOTE THEIR
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
WE NEED AN ECONOMY THAT FEATURES
OVERALL GROWTH AND HIGHER WAGES
FOR WORKING PEOPLE.
BASICALLY THE SAME TYPE OF
ECONOMY WE HAD BEFORE COVID IT.
WE NEEDS TO GET AMERICANS BACK
TO WORK.
-- NEED TO GET AMERICANS BACK TO
WORK.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TRADE AND
IMMIGRATION POLICIES THAT WILL
PREVENT OUTSOURCING JOBS OR
PREVENTING WORKING AMERICANS
FROM MAKING THEIR FAIR SHARE.
WE NEED REALISTIC A PLAN TO DEAL
WITH THE RISE OF CHINA.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT NOW.
THE CURRENT ESTABLISHMENT IS TOO
BIG AND TOO COMPROMISED TO MAKE
THE CHALLENGE PRESENTED BY THE
CCP.
AS THINGS STAND CURRENTLY, I HAD
TO SAVE IT BLUNTLY BUT WE ARE ON
PACE TO LOSE OUR INDEPENDENCE
AND EVENTUALLY BECOME A PUPPET
STATE OF THE CPPP.
WE NEED A COMPLETE REFORM OF OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, OUR
DIPLOMATS.
NO ONE AND I MEAN NO ONE THINKS
CHINA FEARS THIS MAN.
WE CANNOT WAIT FOR THE REST OF
THE WORLD EITHER.
NO ONE BY THE BAY IS CALLING FOR
ISOLATIONISM.
THEY HIT YOU BACK WITH THAT ONE.
IT IS SIMPLY AN ABSURD LOGIC BUT
WE CANNOT WAIT FOR COUNTRIES
LIKE FRANCE, GERMANY, AND JAPAN
TO HELP US.
TO BE CANDID, THE REST OF THE
WORLD THINK THAT AMERICA IS IN
TERMINAL DECLINE AT THIS POINT.
UP AND THAT THE FUTURE PROBABLY
BELONGS TO CHINA.
NO ONE IS GOING TO MAKE
SACRIFICES TO HELP US IF THEY
THINK WE ARE DOOMED.
NUMBER FOUR WE NEED A PATRIOTIC
GOVERNMENT.
TOO MANY PEOPLE IN DC AND I HAVE
BEEN THERE FOR TOO LONG I'M
SORRY TO ADMIT THAT THEY ARE
SERVING TIME UNTIL THEY CAN GO
LOBBY FOR MULTINATIONAL
CORPORATIONS OR EVEN FOR THE
CHINESE.
TOO MANY BROUGHT TO AND
BUREAUCRATS ARE TAKING TAXPAYER
DOUBT TO SIT AT HOME INSTEAD OF
DOING THE NORMAL THING LIKE GO
TO WORK, GO TO THE OFFICE BIG
POPPA TOO MANY OF OUR TRIPLE NET
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE WORLD
THAN DEFENDING OUR NATIONAL
INTERESTS.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AND THE
LARGEST ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND
TRANSFORMATION SINCE THE
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION AND THIS
WOULD BE BIGGER BECAUSE EVERY
NATION IN THE WORLD IS GOING TO
HAVE TO MOVED TO A CLEAN NEW
ENERGY ECONOMY AND FUTURE.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, THAT IS
MUSIC TO CHINA'S ERRORS.
AMERICA IS UNILATERALLY
DISARMING IN THE ENERGY BATTLE
OF CHINA IS BURNING COAL,
BUILDING COAL PLANTS, USING OIL,
UNDETERRED BY THE GREEN
DIPLOMACY.
AS ALL THIS IS HAPPENING, THE
PENTAGON IS MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
BEING WOKE THAN ABOUT PREPARING
TO KILL OUR ENEMIES.
CHECK OUT THIS PRIDE MONTH
PRONOUN TRAINING VIDEO NOW BEING
USED BY THE U.S. NAVY.
>> MY NAME IS JOHNNY AND I USE
HE/HIM PRONOUNS.
WE ARE HERE TO TALK ABOUT
PRONOUNS.
USING THE RIGHT PRONOUNS IS A
SIMPLE WAY TO AFFIRM SOMEONE'S
IDENTITY.
IT IS A SIGNAL OF ACCEPTANCE AND
RESPECT.
>> HOW DO WE GO ABOUT CREATING A
SAFE SPACE FOR EVERYBODY?
>> Laura: MY LORD, THIS IS
EMBARRASSING.
THIS HAS NO PLACE IN OUR
MILITARY OR ANYWHERE, FRANKLY.
THE DEMOCRATS DO BELIEVE THEY
HAVE AN ANSWER TO THIS PERCEIVED
PATRIOTISM DEFICIT.
IT COMES IN THE FORM OF
SOMETHING CALLED A NEW CIVICS
SECURES DEMOCRACY ACT LIKE IT IS
A MOUTHFUL.
JUST REINTRODUCED IN CONGRESS.
IF IT IS PAST, IT WILL ALLOW THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO PUSH
CRITICAL RACE THEORY ON EVERY
PUBLIC SCHOOL IN AMERICA.
OVER A SIX-YEAR PERIOD, SINCE
BILL AND OTHER PART OF
COMPETITIVE GRANT MONEY WILL
CREATE A DEFECT OF NATIONAL
CURRICULUM.
THE FDA HAS ADDED REPUBLICAN
SENATORS, BILL CASSIDY FROM
LOUISIANA AND JIM FROM OKLAHOMA
AS COSPONSORS OF THE NEWLY
INTRODUCED BILL.
UNLESS AMERICA'S PARENTS LICK UP
AND MAKE THEMSELVES HEARD NUGGET
THERE'S A CHANCE THAT CRT COULD
BE THE NEW COMMON CORE BY
SUMMER.
THIS IS INSANE.
BUT EXCEPT FOR THESE FOOLISH
REPUBLICANS GIVING COVERAGE, IT
IS NOT SURPRISING.
MORE ON THIS IN JUST A MOMENT
WITH NEWT GINGRICH.
FOR IS, THAT LEFTIST RED
ANTI-AMERICAN POISON THROUGH OUR
SCHOOLS, MEDIA, MOVIES, EVERY
OTHER FORM.
WE NEED NEW LEADERS WHO ARE
PROUD OF AMERICA AND WHO WORK
EVERY DAY TO DEFEND HER
INTEREST.
NUMBER FIVE, WE HAVE TO MAKE
AMERICA SAFE FOR SOCIAL
CONSERVATIVES.
DESPERATE EFFORT TO HOLD ONTO
POWER, THE CURRENT ESTABLISHMENT
HAS ALIGNED ITSELF WITH RADICALS
ON THE LEFT, JUST WANT TO BAN
SOCIAL CONSERVATIVES INCLUDING
DEVOUT CHRISTIANS, MUSLIMS, AND
ORTHODOX JEWS.
YOU JUST CAN'T PARTICIPATE IN
THE HIGHEST LEVELS IF YOU HAVE
THE WRONG RELIGIOUS BELIEFS.
YOU CAN'T EVEN, HE HAS, FOOTBALL
TEAM.
>> THE THOUGHT THAT ANYBODY OF
ANY KIND OF FAITH WOULD HAVE TO
JUST BE ASHAMED OF THEM BEING
A -- ANYBODY OF FAITH, THAT IS
WRONG IN MY BOOK.
>> Laura: THIS IS NOT ONLY
WRONG.
IT MEANS THAT WE ARE NOT GIVEN
ALL OF OUR BEST AND BRIGHTEST
PEOPLE A CHANCE TO FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN CIVIC LIFE.
THESE ATTITUDES ARE NOT JUST
POISONING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY HAVE INFECTED MANY STATE
AND CITY GOVERNMENTS AND THEY
ARE IN COMMENT WITH THE MEDIA
AND OUR TOP COLLEGES AND EVEN IN
THE MILITARY, THIS HAS TO STOP.
BUT WE DO KNOW HOW TO FIX THESE
PROBLEMS BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT
WORK WITH THE ECONOMY WAS IN
2019, THE POLICIES THAT WOULD
FIX MOST OF THIS BOTH -- THOSE
ARE BEING USED.
THAT THE CLIENT OF AMERICA IS
NOT INEVITABLE.
A NEW SURVEY BY YOU GO TO YAHOO
INDICATE THAT AMERICANS ARE
DISGUSTED WITH JOE BIDEN'S
PERFORMANCE.
IF WITH THE JANUARY 6 MONTHS,
THEY PREFERRED TRUMP NOW IN A
HEAD-TO-HEAD MATCH UP.
WHILE.
AMERICANS NOW THE FIELD
ESTABLISHMENT WHEN THEY SEE IT.
HANDLING OF COVID, ASKED --
AFGHANISTAN, PRICES AT THE PUMP,
GROCERY STORE, CRIME SURGE,
THOUSANDS OF FLIGHTS BEING
CANCELED, THAT WAS FUN, SO BIDEN
TIPPING OVER ON HIS BIKE YEAH,
THAT IS BAD.
BUT AMERICA TIPPING INTO THIRD